film hey are you good to see you how are
you good sure yeah i mean i tunes been
fantastic for us to kind of reach a
global audience you know we wanted to
really compress our window with the film
so we've got a lot of great partners you
were doing it theatrically here in the
united states with reckon he'll and neca
we're doing limited releases with tug
we're putting it out on like itunes on
demand and like through you know other
xbox like you know the other digital
platforms to xbox which is awesome but
for everybody else that are outside the
united states you know we did a deal
with itunes so that anybody can see it's
streaming worldwide yeah and then you're
going on so much work yeah that's right
what are you going to do for some morgan
time so that you can put a recharge and
kind of find that Zen place or is it no
it's full steam ahead but like right now
we're finishing another movie so i'll be
i'll be you know making sure that that
film gets finished as i'm like watching
the color crack dealing with that back
and forth to New York I'm going to do
I'm going to go to the gym a lot I'm
going to sleep in once or twice I'm
going to do some writing like that's
going to be my time like you some other
projects that I want to get a little
head on so I'm going to do some writing
on the road and
yeah that's my way to recharge are you
I'm an introverted extrovert ok yeah I
like a little meantime as I'm sharing my
world right ya go awesome thank you
you